do you want to be featured in one of my
videos so it's really thinking about my
channel and wondering how can I add a
little bit more interaction how can I
give you guys a bit more opportunity to
be involved in what I'm doing an idea
came to me where maybe be fun to do a
mashup some kind of collaboration with
you guys on one of my top 10 video
series so every video that I do for the
top 10 there's three points that I do to
introduce an entrepreneur and then I say
she's Martha Stewart and hear her top 10
rules what I'm thinking of doing is
farming out and collaborating with you
guys to do those first three points and
so you 33 you guys watching would be on
my video and then I would say and here
are her top 10 rules for success I don't
know who I'm going to do it for which
famous entrepreneur yet some of the
criteria gates of what I'd be looking
for is somebody with energy somebody
that has a high quality video somebody
that has good audio you'd be given
basically three sentences to be able to
say and the best three people that I
like I will pull from them and you will
be featured on my channel and also have
a little information about your channel
and what you're all about it's an
opportunity to be featured on the
channel maybe get a little more exposure
if you're interested in this opportunity
just leave a comment below that says I'm
interested and of course your bt a
number for the day and when we're ready
to make that video I'll reach out to you
and tell you what your lines are and
then we'll pull from the top three and
you'll see you on the future one of my
videos